hi everybody welcome back to the
afternoon session um
and uh hi to all our online participants
please write your questions on the chat
and i'll be monitoring it
uh it's a pleasure to
have nia o'hare who's also one of the
co-organizers of this workshop
uh start this afternoon
thanks for the introduction and yes
welcome back
so uh
i think uh we have already heard a lot
of talks on e-max optimization
uh
unfortunately to those who are if you
are already born with a board with new
max organization this will again be me
max optimization but uh luckily i think
on the good news side this is perhaps
also the last talk about me max
optimization for the workshop i think uh
for the next two talks and also the
talks tomorrow will
uh will be more on the learning side and
also uh adversarial approaches
so i think in the last uh in this week
we have already heard a lot of stories
about you know new exciting results
about either classical
uh me max optimization algorithms or
newly developed algorithms and a kind of
a common phenomenon oftentimes we see
it's like those simple algorithms like
gradient descender send or extra
gradient methods may not always be the
best choice of algorithm right they
might not necessarily give you the best
performance whereas algorithms that
gives you better performance or improved
bounce oftentimes require much more
tweaks and also like oftentimes needs to
go to a multiple loop structure
so in this talk i was trying to really
answer the question like
is there hope to get you know simple
single loop algorithms
that achieve potentially even better
performance bonds than those multiple
loop algorithms and in this talk i'm
going to give you kind of two
very cute results say like that closely
some of the gap in the literature
and i should say most of the part of
this talk is based on this very recent
work that is joined with two of my
very amazing collaborators kiran and c1
kiran is a research scientist from
amazon and siwom is a professor at the
university of washington
and this work was just been accepted to
ai stats in 2022
and if i have time i will discuss
another work which has a very similar
flavor but in the stochastic regime okay
all right
so i think whenever we talk about
complexity of me max optimization we
wanted to really be careful that
oftentimes the complexity is related to
three components right first of all what
is the specific problem class that we're
talking about
and this is oftentimes basically
specified by the next smoothness
convexity parameters
right and then it's also the other
element is really what are the
information we're getting from those
objectives or from the problems right
whether it is first order there or order
or whether it is black box or white box
oracles
and there is also what is the notion of
solution concepts here right whether it
is the nash equilibrium or it is the
first order nash equilibrium or maybe
this is some other notion of equilibrium
right so of these were these two
different complexity results right and
by complexity results oftentimes we look
at both on the lower bound side and also
on the upper bound side
and by upper bound we mean that we want
to
find out what is the
least amount of
what is the number of
oracles you need at most right to solve
all problems in this problem class by a
given algorithm and by lower bound we
mean that we want to identify what is
the least amount of efforts you need to
pay
for the all the problems in this problem
class right in the worst case
so and ideally we want to find some
algorithm that's optimal in the sense
that it achieves this lower complexity
bound
okay
and in this talk i will mainly be
restricted to this very generic smooth
minimax optimization problem that was
characterized
by a number of parameters here right so
l corresponds to the smoothness and the
mu corresponds to the strong complexity
strong convex t
so the smoothness here i have lx which
is kind of the smoothness of the
uh
the x component of your gradient right
there is l y which corresponds to the
electricity of the y component of the
gradient right there is l x y which is
uh the gradient the y component of the
gradient what is electricity in terms of
the x base right so basically you can
view these constants that's basically
just the
uh the o2 norms of your
different blocks of your has a matrix
right if your function phi is twice
different differentiable
you can also define what is the strong
convexity right for the x component and
strong convexity for the y component
okay and we know that if mu are greater
than zero those are stronger of x equal
to zero this means it's convex less than
zero it's weekly convex
okay and those are potential those are
non-convex settings
so and we know that most of the talks
that we see are really dividing you know
problems into different regimes based on
the convexity right there is extensive
literature on convex concave strontium
extremely concave settings
more recently there are one more work on
these other settings which are you know
some
uh kind of
in between this convex concave and
non-convex non-concave right
and you can see that
in all these new settings those are
really settings where
there is a some asymmetry between the
two players x and y right the convexity
parameters are different right
whereas in the classical ones oftentimes
we say that
it's kind of more symmetric right
they're either both convex or both
running convex okay
and there's as you can see there's not
much really
division here about the lipschitz
smoothness which is actually equally
important as convex t
so as i said like most of the classic
settings we look at the cases let's say
the we treat kind of a uniform bound for
all of those electric constants lx ly xy
as let's say just
all of them are equal to l or bounded by
l
right and then this the convex t
let's say they're they're also the same
ux equal to mu y right
uh and all of these are oftentimes
captured by variation inequalities right
this was already
i think ineda gave a very good kind of
tutorial or like summary of variation in
quality this morning
right you can basically
say that
we're just interested in this operator f
right which is
neutronic of x or mu surrounding
monotone and elephants right it doesn't
really differentiate
you know those different electricity
constants for different components x and
y right
and we already know of those kind of
stories about the lower bound there
right for this general variation in
qualities with
with monotonicity and the lipschitz miss
and then we als already heard a game in
the game what are the optimal first
other algorithms that can achieve these
lower bound complexities
we talked a lot about extra gradient
right optimistic gda there are also many
other variations
or many other algorithms that provide
the same complexity balance
so what i want to talk about is what
happens if we we
we
uh we look at the cases where those lip
sheets are different or those
strong convexity terms are different
right so because in most cases your
uh
and also in practice maybe those uh as
we see also before right your strong
convexity
parameters mu x mu y in many cases are
not necessarily in the symmetric form
right similarly for the liberation
smoothness terms
so what do we do we know about the lower
complexity bound in this case so the
result was only
established i think there was explicit
description that was given only like a
few years ago by
xiu dongjong and the co-authors right
they shown that
this is
in the case let's say your
both x and y are strongly convex or
strongly concave then you can show that
this is you get linear convergence and
this is the total number of complexity
you need
okay so there is this
there is this condition number which is
the square root of
x over mu x right plus this l x y square
divided by the
product of mu x mu y and then there is
this other term from the y component
side
so
so this results like you look at it it's
also kind of intuitive right like if you
think about let's say
this very special class of problems
which is also very general right so if
you say you have three components in
this five x y right there is the
bilinear structure which is
fairly common
and then there was those separable
functions f x and h y
right and let's say those two are strong
convex okay and then you have bilinear
structure here
so it's kind of intuitive that right if
you don't have these two terms or if
those two terms are very simple let's
say f x and h h y are very simple terms
which you can easily compute their
proximal operators
then you can you can expect that you
will get some bound like this right
you'll get l x y
over square root of mu x mu y right in
in the in the complexity if you run say
approximate point algorithm or if you
run just you know extra gradient method
if you don't have these two terms right
if you just have this f x
right you have to minimize f x right
this is basically the lower bound for
smooth minimization
if you only have this then you have that
right so that's why this is kind of very
intuitive that is this is what you're
expecting right to be the lower bound
okay and i should mention that in fact
the hard instance that was used to
construct this lower bound is fairly
common right it's just a quadratic
problem where f h are quadratic and have
this bilinear structure
right so this is not like
really lower bound for some pathological
hard instances right this is just even
for the most typical problem you would
expect that you have such kind of lower
bound
so what do we know on the upper bound
side right
so of course like you might just pick up
your favorites and say extra gradient or
ogda method and you want to immediately
see that the complexity you get is
basically going to be the again you get
linear convergence right but the
condition number here is going to be the
maximum of the lipsticks constant you
had divide the minimum of your
strong convexity of two components yes
so you need your dimension to maybe
grows your your your your number
iteration
so coming back to extra gradient type of
methods right so this is basically what
you will get
as the complexity
and you can see that it's very different
that actually is much worse than this
floral
and if you use just gradient descend
ascend without extra gradient or this
optimism you get the square of this
condition number right so this is better
than just doing gradient descent ascent
so if you have been to my talk like two
weeks ago at the seminar
then we you you see that we have provide
some like simple
acceleration of extra gradient ogda by
just combining it with the catalyst
acceleration framework you can
immediately boost this convergence to l
divided by square root of mu x u y right
so this square root of mu x mu y this is
better than just taking the minimum
there
and that is like a simple two-loop
algorithm you can you can use
and that you can see that if
if your l right is the same amount of
those components
then this is indeed the optimal you can
shoot for
right
so based on the lower bound this is
actually the best you can shoot for if
your l are uniform among different
components
if those l are not uniformly among those
components then this of course is not
optimal one right at least it's it's
very far away from the lower bound we
see before because in the lower bound
you only have l x y here in this
dominant term here
so there was one work that coming out i
think maybe not last year by uh kohan
and
aram and
kevin i think
and they're shown that
uh if you just don't rebalancing the
kind of the distance generating function
using extra gradient method or mirror
algorithms you actually will be able to
get an improved complexity bound which
looks like this right if you look at
this term you can see that they
basically get a
kind of the optimal term here in terms
of the dependence on this coupling term
lxy right divided by this mu x mu y
but it's not optimal in terms of these
two terms right you can see that if lx
and l white
are very large then this is not this is
much worse than the lower bound we see
before
all right so the lower bound is here so
i should have put it in the other slide
so the square root of these three terms
okay
so lastly i think in the new roof 2020
there was a paper for the proximal
that's the response they provide this
algorithm which is a very sophisticated
four loop algorithm
that combines all kinds of techniques
like
exact processing point algorithm like
best response or terminating updates and
then like
all those like just throw everything
together
and then they're able to achieve this
bound here which is the best known
found i think in the literature so far
right and you can see that it's
very close to the lower bound except
that this middle term here is l x y
times l
l is the maximum amount of your
lipschitz constants right in the lower
bound we have l x y squared okay
and you can see that if l x y
is
uh
let's say if l x y is much smaller than
l right then this is much worse than the
lower bound we see before
if l x y is kind of dominating like it's
very large
then this this is more or less
comparable
uh
to the lower bound right
so this band is kind of more or less
very close but uh
it's still like as the author pointed
out there is still very significant gap
if l x y is two is where more of your mu
x mu y are
very small okay
so
of course the
straightforward question here is
can we close this gap here right and
and also very interesting to see how we
achieve this can we close this gap by
just using a very simple single loop
algorithm instead of having to go
through this for loop five loop
algorithms
to achieve the optimality there
so that is kind of the goal of
of the talk
so maybe i should stop here and see
if you have any idea like do you think
there is any hope that we can
actually close this gap or maybe there
is maybe the lower bound is not tied or
maybe like you won't be able to achieve
it with single loop yes actually we'd
like to ask the question more generally
to the audience for them has everyone
tried to do sos
for the primal gap from the primary
world gap
to understand
can we
is there is there any way to use sos to
understand if the gap
if the constant
even for a class extra gradient to do
[Music]
extra gradient
and i guess you're saying like not
because it has a variation because
try to play the step sizes or something
yes
so i think that's a good question and
those sos advances might be your thing
um you know
tell you how how to choose the right
step size or how to choose the right
algorithm
so here like uh our approach here is
actually our idea here is really fairly
simple right if
and let me just maybe just first give
you the spoiler of and also actually
made
me just first motivate why do we even
care about achieving this close this gap
and achieve achieve the exact optimality
right
because feels like you know the gap is
really small why do we even care about
you know
closing this tiny gap here
and i think the answer to this is really
already given by many of the talks from
yesterday like he may say stuff i think
he talked about
you know if you look at these other
settings right when you have non-convex
concave settings oftentimes you want to
add this more regularization right to
the objective make it strong become
extremely concave
and those regularization are basically
just new here right those are very small
like of order epsilon or even smaller
right so you really want to get the
optimal dependence here with condition
number so that you will be able to
translate it to other settings to get
the optimal dependence on epsilon right
so so it's crucial here
and i think uh uh yesterday uh sohail
also gave a talk on talking about like
how the
the lipstickness actually corresponds to
different robustness right so so it's
really important to get the tight bound
down the lipstick so that you can get
better robustness guarantees as well
right
and why do we care about designing a
single loop algorithm like what's what's
so bad with you know multiple loop
algorithms of course everyone like
simple algorithms that are elegant right
so i think the answer to that is also
like as i eluded before in my other talk
that
if you get a
algorithm
an optimum algorithm for the strong
convex only concave problems you can
easily combine with the catalyst
acceleration or other acceleration
framework to get optimal potentially
optimal linear optimal bounds for those
many other settings
right so if you have a single loop
algorithm here then you'll be able to
just achieve very good you know better
algorithms with good complex guarantees
for all these other settings with just
at most two loop right
okay
so how should we achieve this right and
uh do we have an answer to that and the
answer to the two previous two questions
i had is is
uh we have some positive right with we
we're able to
kind of close the gap for
at least this class of bilinearly
coupled mi max optimization problem as i
mentioned earlier this class of problems
is exactly like the the class of
problems where this lower bank was
constructed from right so this is not
just
a very restrictive class
and the idea is also very simple we use
it based on the primal dual lifting
which i will discuss kind of what is
the details
very soon of course you might be
wondering like can we really relax this
right can we can we
close the gap for even more general
functions that does not limit you to
this bilinear structure
right and the answer i think partly is
yes and there was a recent work that was
released on archive by
i think
who is also here and then a room and
also kevin that has shown that you can
actually use a similar idea and some
other analysis you can show that you can
close the gap for
this more general separable mi max
optimization problems
so that nearly matches with the lower
bound there was a tiny bit of difference
i think
so
lastly i want to mention that these
settings that we're looking at this by
linear mi max organization you might
feel like okay even this has been
already well studied right in the
literature it has been lots of this
primal duo and all kinds of algorithms
to solve it so i want to mention there
are several key differences right so
first of all in most of the literature
when you look at this type of structures
uh they look at cases where your f
function and h function are simple
functions where you can easily compute
their proximal operators right but here
we assume that you only have first order
access to f and h
you cannot compute the proximal
operators right there are other methods
that maybe assume only one of them is
proximal friendly
i think there is another paper i think
that shows uh that is also gets linear
convergence for problems let's say only
one part is running convex the other one
is not strong atomics but a is four and
all these are kind of related but those
are not really fit into the problem
class we consider here okay
so how do we come up with some algorithm
that gets the best condition number
right
so what is the idea here so the idea is
uh
is is basically
that if you wanted to kind of exploit
fully the structure here right there is
this bi-linear structure there is a
smoothness structure here right one to
think about and say what is the optimal
algorithm that
can leverage this bilinear structure
there are many of them there right
one method is like uh uh there's extra
gradient there's prime module and many
others
right what are the algorithms that
leverage the smoothness
to the to its vest right those are like
accelerated gradient methods right of
those
so it came to like a simple idea that
came to us is like you can actually use
just primo dual method
to handle this by linear term with
optimal guarantees you can use also
primal dual algorithm to handle these
smooth terms with optimal guarantee and
then if you just apply primal dual
then you're good to go right so let me
just uh
be a bit more
detailed about that and before that i
want to mention that like
the simplest or the most prominent
examples of this type of problem is just
you know quadratic minimax problems
which actually occur pervasively in the
literature
like there's
like if you have a matrix games but you
have some quadratic constraints right
you can formulate this way
if
if you look at the robust least square
it's also like exactly this type of form
if you look at say just the
policy evaluation objective like the
minimized mean square projected by my
error is exactly like gives you this
type of objective
when you use linear function
approximation
it's not really just a limited
problem class here okay so what is the
inspiration here we got to solve this
problem
so the first idea the first
thing as i said we want to look at this
bilinear structure and see how we can
handle it and we know in the literature
right if you have bi-linear structure
and if you have some function list i'm
using capital f and capital h here let's
say those are
astronomy convex and those are functions
that you can easily compute their
proximal operators right i call them
proximal friendly here
so one way of course to solve this
problem as we all know is you can use
the shampoo lip primal dual method
right you
you
you take this exfoliation step for y
right and then you do
this by linear term plus some breakdown
divergence and
this function f you just keep it intact
here when you minimize this right you do
the same for y right alternatively
so this is just a prime module method
you can actually view this primal dual
algorithm as just an approximation again
as proximal point algorithm just like
extra gradient or optimistic gradient
descent ascent right if you apply
proximal point algorithm to this problem
that will exactly give you these two
updates except that you're not going to
have y theta here you have y t plus one
and you have an explicit update here
and here
prime module method basically says
instead of using y t plus one which you
cannot compute you replace it by this
extrapolated by t plus one theta
right that's it
and you can just follow the analysis of
proximal point algorithm and easily
analyze this prime module and get this
iteration complexity okay for solving
this problem
which as i said is optimal for solving
this class of problems
so these are very classical right this
is being well known
so what about the
smooth minimization like f of x this
part right if you want to minimize f x
we know that the best algorithm to solve
it is this rows accelerate the gradient
descent method
and that also has a primal dual
perspective so let me elaborate that
right if you want to minimize f of x
this is equivalent let's say f is mu
strong convex this is equal to minimize
you decompose it into terms right there
is the quadratic term plus f x minus
this quadrature here which i denote as f
underline here
and this f underline here is convex
right you can rewrite it as
using its essential dual
right so you can rewrite this objective
just
f f underlined by maximize over mu of
this inner product minus essentially do
all right so you have this mean max
reformulation
if you look at this mean max formulation
it's exactly the same form as what i
discussed before right you have simple
term here another simple term here a
bilinear structure here
you can solve it by primal dual
algorithm right just apply the previous
primal dual algorithm to solve this
this is what you will get okay
and you can see that in this case your
mu x right is mu
and the your bin linear term matrix a
there is just identity so your lips is
constant l x y is equal to one okay
and your mu y is going to be the
strong convexity of this term into dual
right you know that
f is l smooth right your f under 9 here
is l minus mu smooth right this venture
dual is strong convex
of parameter inverse of one l minus mu
right
so you're plugging this into the
previous
bond we know here right your norm of a
is just one mu x is mu mu is l minus mu
inverse you get automatically
the iteration complexity which is
exactly the optimal rate you would be
achieved by accelerated gradient descent
okay
and in fact when you look at this
algorithm you might say okay how can how
am i going to compute this
this problem here right i have the
breakman divergence here
i have this
finger dual here
and in fact if you just write down the
uh
this this update here and you can show
that it actually exactly translates
you update exactly translate to the
update because u is in the dual space it
actually translates to the updating the
gradient
right so this is just an equivalent
reformulation or like
if you just rewrite these three updates
it's going to give you this
okay and this is exactly just
accelerated gradient descent
so this
right so so so this is also
like you
add some negative momentum write your
gradient and then you update your x
right with this this gradient term
either you add some convex combination
steps for for those two iterations
this game perspective of
accelerated gradient descent is not
really new right this was first i think
identified by
george land in 2018
right so
our kind of analysis is slightly
different from the errors by just this
extrapolation step there is another
you can do extrapolation on x or
explanation on mu right there is just
slight variation there otherwise it's
the same okay so there is okay nothing
new here
okay so now you can see that we can use
prime module to handle bilinear problem
we can use prime module to hang smooth
terms
and then if you have those
this original problem we have in mind
and natural ideas let's just try to run
prime module here right and this first
as we did before
we write this f of x
and delete it to the dual
okay
we're maximizing over
mu right we just rewrite this f x by
maximizing this part here
similarly we do it for h right we
we definitely to the dual space by
minimizing over v right this is the dual
for that
and this part remains come
in like remains the same
right and if you yes
sure so to minimize f of x
is equivalent to minimize
maximize
over u of this term
right so so i'm just rewriting f of x as
a maximum over u
and this
and then i'm rewriting h of y as
minimizing v of this
right so i can switch me max because
here there's there's a strong duality
because
it's strongly convex concave compact
like
well-defined closed
comb access yeah
uh-huh so the others doesn't really
matter that that's why i'm merging them
here right just minimize over x v
instead of writing as me max mean max
so it's basically the dual of this me
max optimization problem so the duo of
mi max is going to be still me max
okay so a nice feature of this
reformulation right is that if you look
at this reformulation you can see that
they're all simple terms right
so this differential this is
differential u of f f f under 9 this is
a very simple term you can easily handle
it as before
this quadratic term is simple very
simple and this term is also simple and
then you only have those binomial
structure here
okay
so there's only bilinear structure plus
a bunch of proximal friendly terms
okay
and you can just apply primal dual
algorithm to solve it right
so if you apply the primal dual
algorithm to solve it right it's just
the extrapolation steps on your
variables
right you just throw it the gradient
here
and you break my divergence here right
and then those simple terms you just
keep it
intact in the in the sub problems right
so this is
primal dual algorithm
of course similarly as before you can
see that this when you do this fragment
divergence to
to update you those are basically
equivalent to just updating on the dual
space which is updating the gradients
okay so basically what you have like
this is the equivalent reformulation or
translating that is basically you update
your x
right
with this extrapolation steps right you
update your gradient for both x and y
right and then you plug in your gradient
and update the x and y and then you do
some other
complex combinations of previous
iterates
everything is basically
similar as before except we have an
extended space not just x and y but x y
and u v okay
and we do this right so and
you can analyze it very easily just
following kind of similar analysis of
the original primary algorithm
and you can show that access results
converge linearly
and it converts linearly with this
exponential decay rate that relates to
kappa and kappa is exactly equal to this
you know this term here what i define
here
right and to translate that this
basically means that the gradient
complexity you need is basically of this
order which
exactly matches the lower bound we see
before
okay so
shouldn't come
up as much of a surprise here right yeah
because as i said when we formulate this
as this
and you see that you only need gradient
updates here
so it's first order matters yeah
and i should also mention that the lower
bound that people come up with here this
uh
is applies to first order matters that
includes single loop multiple loop
algorithms okay
at this point
all right
so
so this seems to be like the end of the
story right we're able to close you know
the gap and match with the
lower bound exactly
of course the next thing you might be
wondering is what about you know if you
don't have strong convexity on both
sides let's say if your objective is
convex on one side but strongly concave
on the other side
right so you can you can you can like
like what base mason discussed yesterday
right you can add this of other epsilon
quadratic term to your objective make it
strongly convex running concave right
that corresponds to basically you have
now strongly connection concave
objective with mu x equal to of order
epsilon
right if
if you just plug in this
other epsilon term into this lower bound
here right to replace mu x by epsilon
this mu x by epsilon right this is what
you will get right the complexity
and this complexity
it's basically nearly optimal right you
can see this component because you're
dealing with a smooth minimization
problem this is the best you can hope
for
this other term here you're dealing with
bilinear structure with swani
but this is also the best you can hope
for
right this
this uh this logarithmic term one over
epsilon times this condition number
is the best complex you can get for
solving a strongly concave minimization
parabola
right so each of those terms are optimal
right i said this near optimum because
this is this one the wraps now has this
addition log christmas one directional
here right this logarithmic should
really only appear for this condition
number not this other two okay
and this is also the best i
i think this is the best known result in
literature
if you uh of course you might say i
don't really want to use music because i
have to choose what is this new x right
it's not
it requires some tuning
if i actually just apply the same
algorithm i discussed before lifted
primal dual algorithm by just instead of
using a constant step size you can use
some decaying step size instead just
like what you do in the convex concave
settings and then you can show that it
actually gives this one over t square
convergence rate
and that leads to the following gradient
complexity right which is again
dominating term is of order one over
square root of epsilon which is the best
you can hope for right
and the so you basically get one over
square root of epsilon four for each of
those terms right so it is
not as good as this one as you can see
right because this one for this
condition number on the y component you
are supposed to get linear convergence
right log on the reps no but you get
this one over square root of x
if you recall what i discussed in the
in the
uh in the talk i gave before like
actually you can get this one over
square root of epsilon term also with
log one over epsilon by
just using catalyst plus extra gradient
ogda
right this is strictly worse than this
one
if you look at the dependence on this uh
lipschitz smoothness time okay
and i should note that these two
complexity bonds are the best known
amount of the algorithms known so far
and the and the the reason why these are
best is also is really because like
we're able to close this gap and get the
optimal dependence here at first place
all right so just a quick summary here
like we're able to actually design
single loop you know optimal algorithm
for solving by linear
bilinearly coupled with max problems
with strong convexity on both sides
i mentioned earlier there was a work by
yuja and aeron and kevin that they were
able to further you know
relax to generally coupled uh
like general coupling instead of just by
linear coupling right of course the
intriguing question is are we able to
further extend this to more general max
optimization problem without having to
separate fx and hy out of your objective
right just arbitrary phi of x y
so this remains an unknown uh an open
question there and can we extend this to
we've shown we can extend the results to
other settings like strongly convex
concave or convex running concave but
can we extend it to non-convex settings
right
one idea of course if you use the
catalyst or those other acceleration
mechanisms or smoothing mechanisms you
will be able to get good results for
these other settings but you will end up
with having at least two loops instead
of one loop so whether you can you know
further reduce
uh further further modify the algorithms
to make
to get a single loop algorithm
to achieve optimal rates on those
settings is still unknown
and also how can we generalize those two
you know stochastic or financial
settings
so i think there are in general lots of
really interesting open questions there
that can be done
okay what is the finance
uh finite sum is basically objective is
like just one over n summation
and different components
uh any questions for now
yes
yeah first of all the idea is very nice
and very simple
any
clue on
whether you could extend the same
techniques or like there is no hope to
do similar similar things to other
settings to uh yeah non-separable let's
say oh to non-separable case
any of these questions
could you use a similar idea
yeah for for this non-separable one
[Music]
not sure i think i think the prime
module approach might not
cannot be easily extended to in general
like the general mi max optimization
problem like the primal duo are really
optimal when you have this binding your
structure but to be on the bilinear
structure those are not always the
optimal algorithm
right so so
here there is a question mark here is
this this lifting idea is the best thing
to do it's possible right because you
can still lift you can still have
like a dual formulation of me max
problems
not necessarily by linear but it's more
like you have to you have to design what
is the conjugate of you know in general
like a max optimization
so so so there's a lot of sophistication
there so it's not that straightforward
but this other i think the other
technique in hijab the other work they
were using something more like
relatively smooth those are a bit more
general than this
time module perspective yeah
and your answer to these other settings
your answer is yes i i i didn't have
time to cover my second part but
you can actually propose very simple
like primo dual type methods and you can
deal with like stochastic settings and
even settings without strong concavities
and you'll be able to show like much
better improved
you know dependence on condition numbers
for these settings comparing to existing
methods like this is i think what mason
talked about yesterday right where you
have this gdmax type of methods which
has much higher dependence on condition
numbers but you can actually get much
better
dependence on condition number
with this like simple single loop
algorithm using some some of these
primal dual ideas
also in the stochastic setting you can
get kind of the best dependence on
condition numbers without really
having to go through two loop algorithms
so it's possible for many other settings
but not necessarily
you know the
very general one yeah
yes
thank you a lot that's a very nice talk
i was wondering a little bit for the
non-convex setting because i'm not very
familiar in that case i wonder if there
are any non-single loop algorithms for
these settings and what the ideas is
based on right so
for instance
so here we can look at like say generous
the past optimization problem which is
non-convexing x
but it is also not necessarily not
concaving why let's say here i'm
considering for instance like problems
that satisfy the pl condition here for
the y component right this does not
necessarily require anything like
concavity or strong concavity in y
right you can have single loop
algorithms to solve it right i have this
maybe a summary
here or maybe this one
right if you like this is non-convex
objective right if you just apply
stochastic gradient the center ascent
you would expect it to have some complex
like epsilon negative four
and it was like put cubic dependence on
condition number and that requires you
to also use
very large batch sizes at every
iteration to estimate the gradient if
you don't use large batch there was
a work i think this is work by uh tne
lin and trijin and michael jordan right
they've shown that you don't use a mini
badge you get worse complexity like
epson negative five
but what we've shown that you actually
you don't need a mini batch you don't
need two loop you can have a single loop
algorithm
right that achieves this epsilon
negative four with much smaller
dependence on kappa
and without even using requiring
anything like strong concavity of that
yeah
what does the framework of the pelvis so
the framework of the algorithm is also
very similar to this primal dual right
except that you are not using the true
gradient here is just an unbiased
gradient
here
and then there was also some like
explanation steps
thank you
and actually i didn't show the
numerical results right this is
basically what everyone will play with
waterstone games for this type of
problems here let's say you have a
non-convex
uh
strongly concave problems i'm using just
a neural network for the generator but
just quadratic discriminator here so i
think yesterday uh gaussian has talked
about like the performance of adam right
so here what we observed that yes in in
general adam performs better than you
know just a running gradient descended
ascent
okay but we've shown that if you have
this you know
site modification of this gradient
descent ascent with this alternating
structure and with this smoothing then
you can actually get even better
performance than adam
it doesn't really require a lot of
tuning or anything right so there's also
like a lot of promise
on the numerical side of these single
loop algorithms
all right i think i have all the
references here and if you are
interested to
uh look into some of the details feel
free to send me an email and i can i'm
happy to share the slides
[Music]
if you apply your algorithm
get optimal rate like two loops right
uh
first of all we don't know the optimal
[Music]
are there any other albums that they can
do two loops foreign
[Music]
like this way
and they have a very high order of
always dependence fully level with the
current here and you can i think you can
use the trick right
to
to improve these results mostly on the
condition
so the uh catalyst framework or you know
frameworks of this type i wonder like
they have two loops but like can you how
is there a generic uh at least i mean
approach to just do two time scale
methods to say okay it's one loop but
like
right uh
exactly right so this one i didn't go
into the details here but this is like
exactly like
like you just run one step of the
catalyst
so like the sub problems originally you
would use multiple steps to solve it to
some accuracy but you can just in in
some settings you can just afford just
one step
instead of multiple steps because the
sub problems are strongly connect
strongly concave so running for constant
number of steps
is
gives you comparable performance as
running for like logarithmic one reps
number iterations
so in many cases you can
just
reduce it directly to a single loop
but uh yeah
so our analysis we will only analyze for
several cases it's not like every of
these settings you can you can do this
reduction there
uh
i show it here
i have an additional slide is like the
algorithm that i talked earlier that
follow problems against you that is as
you can see it's fairly complicated
there i didn't put in my stuff yeah i
think that in general for all these
other settings it's possible to you know
it's possible to uh improve the catalyst
to make it just one loop
but uh
there is
some sophisticated analysis that you you
need
if you and if you don't care about the
addition logarithmic factor that's fine
but if you care about this logarithmic
factor then you have to use a lot of
techniques like warm starting like the
way uh
and also
maybe some other techniques to get rid
of those
additional logarithmic terms
all right thanks for the questions yeah
happy to talk more offline
thanks again